methamphetamines another level the the
the the world of methamphetamine if you
are unfortunate enough to have forever
get into it is so violent and so gross
and so crazy it
it only gets hotter doing that no Joe no
mike is a good story go to buy meth
outlet desert oh so my friend we would
normally we get we would get meth from
this guy this guy was not over he said
but I'm going to because you have been
buying meth for me for like six months
straight I'm gonna give you the number
for the guy I get it from you cut out
the middleman yes smart and I go oh
Heisenberg and we go out to the Apple
Valley like straight out of [ __ ]
Breaking Bad we are driving forever into
tumbleweeds and cactuses and there's
this [ __ ] Shack and this dude comes
out and greets us in a wife-beater not
like super buff but thick shave head
fully fully visible swastika and SS
tattoos and were like oh what the [ __ ]
yeah what do we do it and my friend
moves with me tougher and cooler than I
am and shame is he Latino no he's he's
like he's like a surfer brah white guy
he goes why that's right yeah and and he
was like I'm so area um so he gets and
we're like okay he's like you did Conan
so we go inside and this guy's name is
vamp and he has he's like 11 feet tall
and like 90 pounds in and his hair is
jet black down his booty decks a - no no
- no - oh um shirtless but thin thin
teeny like imagine like like like
Marilyn Manson like I just peek when he
was thin and look kinda like that and we
go to this table and he has a [ __ ]
collection of meth like big rocks of
meth and we were like you guys why I
don't know maybe like do you think
coordinators I go you know that'll be
250 bucks and we like armed okay yeah
let's go got a standard price turn forty
bucks
we were buying like a lot of my ultimate
yeah we were bought we were buying more
like typically buy like an Eightball but
you we were getting like a quarter I
think or no balls how much I've no idea
behave in ounce so we're gonna uh oh I
bought in 1996 it was like 75 to 100
bucks yes cheaper now right I don't know
it's probably more prolific message or
sees me more ubiquitous so it might be
cheaper but we sit down at the table a
big circular table but big and we're
sitting there and a [ __ ] place is a
mess
the teeny little [ __ ] jacket was
missing and we're talking and there's a
cat over here to the on encounter by the
sink and the cats walking all looking
all the [ __ ] and there's an empty open
box of chips ahoy know what bat was a
mini bag of chips ahoy you know like
than anyone's
yeah the personal package that answers
and it's open and the cat's putting his
head in like this and I'm looking over
that and all of a sudden here guys
pulled a gun out from the table [ __ ]
shot the cat just like a cartoon and you
know a gun shot is especially when
you're not prepared for oh my god why
Brian he's just staring me dead dead
eyes like this and my friends trying to
play cool he's like I said he's tougher
than the friendly handle himself
probably in jail like I'm a [ __ ] and
I'm chill chill bro chill it's alright
and and I'm [ __ ] terrified I didn't
pee myself but I was so close and I was
so close to crying like a [ __ ] in front
well cause he's prettier like I'm gonna
die now yeah I'm like not only not only
did he fire a gun indoors kill the cat
he had a gun hidden that he didn't want
it's a lot of process so we got so far
get in the car and we're driving and
we're silent for like 30 minutes and I'm
look over the past year I was like dude
never doing that again I'm never talking
to that guy again I'm never [ __ ]
dealing with that that is one of the
most traumatic things that's ever
happened
ten minutes after we were done with that
bag Wow the TV apart like to whatever
you see things be taken apart it's
always mad I took my friend Jason
Sutton's television apart because I was
convinced Conan O'Brien was talking me I
did was one of those 90s TV is like a
giant talk ever
yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue Oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]